sillonnez les plus belles plages de
l'île à la recherche des meilleures
prises de vue c'est le travail en or de
jeunes martiniquais géographe de
formation
aujourd'hui c'est leur première sortie
sur le terrain avec leurs formateurs
vidéos et photos ce qu'il veut en vaut
vraiment stabilisé tu peux faire un peu
comme les gars qui sont toujours au
physique le bloquent leur respiration où
il souffle lancement façon d'être stable
paysage plage oeuvres sculptées dans la
roche
il s'agit de cartographier les plus
beaux atouts de la destination
martinique
c'est très important parce que je fais
une maîtrise en développement du
tourisme donc c'est déjà quelque chose
qui me touche puis valoriser mon île
c'est quelque chose d'intéressant sur
touba à l'échelle européenne aussi donc
pour l'instant c'est une première phase
avec la communauté d'agglomération de
l'espace sud mais on espère étendre le
programme à l'ensemble de l'île
ces quatre jeunes en service civique
travail tant fait pour une plateforme
qui répertorie les plus belles routes
bleues à travers l'europe
ils font la promotion des destinations
touristiques européennes tournée vers la
mer toutes ces images seront ensuite
répertoriées sur le site de 10 et 11 ans
va maintenant mettre un tourisme en
intégrant sur le logiciel geodis et 1
le but est de mettre en avant les
acteurs du territoire aussi bien sociaux
économiques ou que ce soit les
entreprises du tourisme mais aussi les
producteurs c'est vraiment de lier terre
et mer et pouvoir faire le lien en fait
par les entrées par la mer qu'on pouvoir
amener les personnes les voyageurs mais
aussi les personnes sur place à pouvoir
découvrir le territoire en aussi bien
par les entrées maritimes que dans les
terres pour une commune comme rivière
pilote qui n'a qu'un petit accès à la
mer cette opération de valorisation
permet d'attirer des touristes
alors les jeunes n'hésitent pas à
s'aventurer dans les environs comme ici
à trous au diable ja c'est un bon point
de vue en fait c'est un très beau site
qui serait intéressant déjà de mettre en
valeur et puis
c'est un site sur lequel on passe
généralement mais on s'arrête pas
forcément et du coup là c'est l'occasion
d'un terreau de mettre en valeur sur la
plateforme en fait promouvoir une
croissance bleue un tourisme éco citoyen
un milieu du tourisme de masse le projet
odyssea est également pourvoyeur
d'emplois une dizaine sera créée autour
de ce projet d'inventaire et d'ici trois
ans une centaine pour accompagner les
demandeurs d'emploi vers le secteur
touristique